(upbeat music)
- [Reporter] The McAloo Tikki
burger, McPops, onion rings.
If you don't recognize these items
from your regular McDonald's menu,
that's because you can't get them
at a regular McDonald's in the US.
They're exclusive to McDonald's
in their respective countries.
♪ The all-new McAloo Tikki ♪
♪ $2 ♪
- [Reporter] Designed to
both attract tourists.
- [Tourist] America does not
have these fries or wings.
- [Reporter] And more importantly,
drive international sales.
- When you look at the sales figures,
about 41% of their sales are in the US
and all the rest are international.
- [Newsreader] Here's how and why
the company designs those local menus.
This is "The Economics of
McDonald's International."
McDonald's founder, Ray Kroc
opened his first restaurant
in Illinois in 1955
with just three food items on the menu.
Its staple was a 15 cent hamburger.
It first moved outside the
continental US in 1967.
Now the company has
over 40,000 restaurants
in over 100 countries.
- We think of McDonald's
as an American company,
and in the US they have
about 13,500 restaurants.
But the bulk of their restaurants
are actually international.
So all the rest of those restaurants,
about 27,000, are all around the world.
- [Reporter] And you may have noticed
that the restaurants look different.
- This is so chic.
There's no Grimace, no Hamburglar.
- [Heather] In Canada they offer poutine.
(narrator speaking French)
- [Reporter] While global core items
like burgers and fries
make up most of McDonald's
food sales still,
these local menu items make up about 30%.
International sales are a key
part of McDonald's revenue.
Australia, China, Japan,
France, and Germany
are a few of the company's top markets.
Adopting a menu like this
is a strategy companies
use called localization,
and it's a tactic that has been essential
to McDonald's global growth.
When the company expanded
into India in 1996,
it did so without any beef on its menus.
observing the common belief in the country
that cows are sacred.
McDonald's served more than
6 million customers there
its first year with items
like the Maharaja Mac,
made with mutton patties.
One of India's current
popular items is this,
the McAloo Tikki Burger.
- It's a potato and pea patty
blended with some Indian spices.
- [Reporter] This is Roger Di Domenico.
He works with local teams to
build international menus.
- They remind me of a
certain Indian Street food
that I had growing up.
So I think it's just a
wonderful way to recognize
and get closer to the customers
while still remaining McDonald's.
- [Reporter] Most McDonald's
locations globally
are managed and owned by
franchisees or licensees
rather than the company.
Deciding what's on those menus
starts with customer research.
Local experts use that
research to craft new items.
Local flavors are
incorporated in several ways.
The first is adapting McDonald's staples
to fit specific tastes.
- I think if you look at
the Spicy Chicken McNuggets
that have been in multiple markets,
each one of those markets has
a different interpretation
of what spice means to their consumers.
There'll be one that might
be highlighting curry.
There might be one that highlights
more of a Tabasco-like flavor.
And then a third one
that will use something
like a Thai chili or a jalapeno.
- [Reporter] But some markets
will create or offer
something completely new.
Mexico has McMolletes
as part of breakfast.
The Philippines serves fried
chicken with McSpaghetti.
- If it's something that tastes like home
and can be both true to McDonald's
and true to the consumer,
it's a big win for us.
- [Reporter] And some additions
to the international menus
compete with other restaurants.
- In some of these countries,
McDonald's definitely competes
with a brand like KFC on chicken.
So in some countries in the Middle East,
they actually offer fried chicken,
which is not something
you'd see on US menus.
But to compete with these
local flavors, they do that.
- [Reporter] Some of the more
popular international items
have even spread to
McDonald's menus globally.
- McFlurry started off in Canada
and now it's loved everywhere.
McSpicy is a product that started off
as a local taste variation in China
that has now been adopted
all over the world.
We want people to come in
for the global core icons.
We want people to come
in to try something new.
And so any of the menu items
that we feel like will do that
is what we wanna elevate in the system.
- [Reporter] McDonald's
seized on the popularity
of South Korean boy band BTS,
launching a limited edition BTS meal
in a number of countries in 2021.
It included sweet chili and Cajun sauces
inspired by the South Korean market.
The company said the
promotion helped drive
a 40% increase from the
year before in global sales
and significantly lifted McNugget
sales during that period.
(BTS singing)
But some transplants aren't so successful.
- For a number of years
McDonald's has had a
McVegan sandwich in Germany
and some other European countries.
They recently tried offering
what they called a McPlant,
which was using a Beyond
Meat burger in the US,
and they tested that in some markets.
And it just doesn't seem the
consumers here want that.
So, you know, there is a push, pull.
You know, it's fun to have
new flavors, it's exciting,
but it doesn't always
work in a permanent way.
(slow music)
- [Reporter] While having a wide selection
of items globally is profitable,
McDonald's is looking to
streamline some of its offerings.
- This year the CEO, Chris K has said
that there's just too many redundancies
all across the world.
He gave an example where, you know,
there's 70 different types
of chicken sandwiches
all across the world.
And so I think they are in
the process of examining that,
but I don't think they're gonna eliminate
all local items on menus.
- [Reporter] So next time you're in Spain
you might be able to try McPops.
- They're filled with your choice
of white chocolate or hazelnut.
They're super soft
and they've got this amazing
filling on the inside.
Can I bother for a napkin?
- [Speaker] Yeah, napkin (indistinct).
(Roger laughing)